[Musique]
premier jour de visite pour Agnès Firmin
le Bodo la ministre délégué chargée de
l'organisation territoriale et des
professions de santé est arrivée sur
notre île ce vendredi 23 septembre et
c'est sur le territoire de l'Est au GHR
de Saint-Benoît qu'elle a débuté son
séjour consacré à la thématique des
violences intrafamiliales cette
rencontre a été l'occasion pour le
département et les acteurs locaux de
présenter à la ministre les actions
déployées pour lutter contre ce fléau
madame la ministre à l'occasion de cette
visite intervient en premier sur le
problème des violences intrafamiliales
ici à la Réunion le sujet est
extrêmement important et le département
est très présent notamment quand nous
avons 13 travailleurs sociaux qui
travaillent dans les commissariats et
les casernes de gendarmerie arrêtent les
autorités judiciaires pour accompagner
les victimes de ces violences
les femmes les enfants aussi il faut le
souligner et à chaque fois que cela est
nécessaire et bien notre accompagnement
se met en place et bien évidemment nous
faisons en sorte que les victimes soient
mises à l'abri de plus rapidement
possible et le travail associatif avec
toutes les aides qu'on apporte des
associations sur l'ensemble du
territoire de Lille pour faire en sorte
que cet accompagnement soit bien réalisé
performant au-delà de l'accompagnement
des victimes nous faisons en sorte que
les mesures de prévention soit les plus
forts renforcer la parentalité lutter
contre les addictions renforcer
l'éducation l'éducation populaire ici
nous sommes de la société du vivre
ensemble et bien le vivre ensemble c'est
aussi au sein des familles c'est pour
cela que nous devons éradiquer le
problème des violences intra familiales
pour le département il était important
de faire le point sur l'accompagnement
des victimes au sein des commissariats
et gendarmerie un travail de mise en
confiance du public qui se fait avec
l'aide des associations ici c'est vrai
qu'on travaille en partenariat on a un
beau partenariat avec les gendarmes ce
qui a facilité aussi de la libération de
la parole parce que on a on a pu
sensibiliser les femmes en leur disant
les gendarmes ne font pas là que pour
reprendre pour faire de la reportion
mais aussi pour aider ils sont aussi
dans le social et les accompagner
l'année dernière ce sont 1657 femmes et
407 mineurs victimes qui ont bénéficié
de l'aide des intervenants sociaux en
commissariat et gendarmerie depuis 2022
on en dénombre 13 répartis sur les 5
micro-régions de l'île monsieur le
président du Département je suis
conseillère départementale quand
j'entends les félicitations qui sont
apportées à l'engagement du département
en collaboration pour fournir des
travailleurs sociaux
dans les commissariats je me dis que
voilà tout ce que vous faites ici est
exemplaire parce que vous avez tous
conscience que la cause
nécessite et que l'enjeu est important
certes il y a encore j'imagine des
choses à améliorer j'imagine que sur
l'éducation et sans aucun doute sur la
prévention sans aucun doute donc
peut-être le moyen le nombre de
logements nécessaires pour après la
prise en charge sur les logements
d'urgence mais vous avez là un modèle un
modèle qui à mes yeux est exemplaire qui
mérite et qui devrait être dupliqué mais
vous avez tous bien conscience que c'est
en travaillant collectivement vous avez
chacun des compétences et vous les
mettez au service de ces femmes et
hommes et enfants qui subissent des
violences intrafamidales les violences
intrafamiliales demeurent un sujet
prioritaire pour le département de La
Réunion qui poursuit son travail afin
d'améliorer la prise en charge des
victimes la collectivité entend par
exemple mettre en place une astreinte
des ISCG avant la fin de l'année
[Musique]